I grabbed one Hey grab a microphone yeah
grabbing microphones it's you look so
much like Seth Meyers to me oh hush you
do join the club and to join it but I
saw him I saw him a couple nights ago
and he was like man I look like Thomas
Middleditch we get you a worse
microphone I don't know what if I change
it does nope that's zero
now that test we're filming yeah I'm
always wary of things that you do that
people could turn into internet things
of dicks yeah
no it's definitely going to help yeah uh
my producer Nick told me that you're
getting your pilot's license yeah I
didn't know that
oh yeah yeah what do you do it a guy
owes me he points the dials and tells
him what they do and I go okay and then
he gives me like five books that are all
this thick and I have to know it all and
then what I do I will take to the skies
and fight the Germans why do you want to
do that and it's been a dream able to
dream it would be do this alright why
are we talking about pilot's license buy
my new tie you have to do time pilot
inside tie well you get are you gonna be
the dad I guess I'll be the dad okay
this is something we just do for our own
pleasure Thomas plays a hyperactive boy
yeah and I'm his his dad and you blocked
me out yeah so just pretend like you got
it sounds like you got you've got a lot
of like groceries look at you like the
sliding door woman okay tie
hi unlock the door buddy Tyler no Tyler
that Street no need pizza stop meeting a
comically large slice of pizza time no
see
give me a contact where you would say
Pizza jammers oh if the thing has no
meanings and hits up for you to decide
drink absent and disappear can use a
drink
absolutely yeah and then it makes you
disappear you haven't had absolutely
what's your new policy in a sauna do you
go for it my new policy I'm nude your
nude all nude understand nude no qualms
love it don't boo me fell is that real I
go to nudes falls in Los Angeles just
trolling looking no there's a aia i free
went to a Korean stolen
the Google ylang-ylang if you can't let
the ding-a-ling ring a cup of company of
old man when can you let a dingaling
ring private time alone see once I did
that once I got over it and started
messing around nude with all those I
just feel so much better about what he
did because it's optional like people
can wear yeah I'm the only one that
doesn't got so much moisture in my areas
are you sweating yeah yeah yeah I ran
here and this is a new shirt it's tight
on the pits
Kiana baby
how good is your be tight on the pit cuz
I got these broad shoulders I'm a sling
guy with wide shoulders what do you want
a medal
get all the move back
is it fun for everyone else
oh do an impression of Seth Meyers bring
up the next go no I don't know how yes
how you did it for your SNL edition oh I
did hey this is me at Seth Meyers
I always say you're doing falling out it
would have been okay but Lorna Michael
says otherwise
oh well I just got to settle for an HBO
show Michael you know to watch crack is
in the fries in the front around I can't
wait to see the P Harold sure I got here
early
I'm gonna give it a try surely they're
not making fun yeah I won't touch her